Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody, to the
David Pakman Show.
My name is Luke Beasley.
I'm going to be filling in for David today
while he is away on paternity leave.
Obviously exciting stuff going on.
Huge congratulations to David and his family.
We will.
Massive show to get into.
So let's dove right in.
Last night, the January 6th committee held
their first big public hearing where they
started the process of going through all of
the information they have gathered over the
last number of months.
And I thought that the chairman, Congressman
Thompson, as well as Liz Cheney, who kind
of led the presentation for the night, did
a really good job of outlining a few main
points.
So we're going to do a bird's eye view, look
at these main points, and then we're going
dove into some specific moments.
The first is Donald Trump was absolutely supportive
and they made this very clear of the rioters.
He was watching it unfold and he was supportive
of it.
And as we're going to get into in just a second,
he was even.
CHEERING on, supportive of the rioters who
wanted to kill his own vice president.
The second big thing was he absolutely was
told by people close to him repeatedly that
the claims he was making were false.
I think we had all kind of assumed that, but
that was shown as well.
People like former Attorney General William
Barr and his own daughter Ivanka Trump were
aware that the election was not stolen.
There's no evidence for that.
And yet Trump kept perpetuating it.
The third big thing was there was a clear
and planned, coordinated effort to attack
the Capitol by the Proud Boys and the Oath
Keepers.
And the reason why I say that is because there
was some question of was it just a protest
that got out of hand or was it a premeditated
event by some people?
And at least in the case of the Proud Boys
and the Oath Keepers, it was premeditated.
And that's a big deal.
The fourth big thing, and this is the most
important part of all of this is Donald Trump
was the first U.S. president in all of our
history to not respect the peaceful transition
of power.
And that is huge because that is absolutely
necessary to holding together our democracy.
And he just spit all over it because he was
just upset.
He lost an election.
He stomped on our entire history of doing
a really good job.
The person who's in power, if they lose, they
respectfully exit and do what they can to
make it a peaceful transition.
And so that put our democracy in peril.
And that's a huge point we have to keep stating
so that everyone does not forget it.
Obviously, these videos can't be super, super
long, so I can't go through everything that
I would want to from this hearing because
there was a lot jam packed into it.
The stuff that I can't cover, I'll try to
get to some of it on my own show so you can
find that at Luke Beazley on YouTube.
If you're watching this on YouTube or listening
to the podcast, it'll be in the description
box, a link to my channel, but definitely
check out my show, Luke Beazley on YouTube.
But I also encourage you to watch the whole
hearing if you haven't already yourself, because
there is tons of stuff there, super, super
important for you to be aware of that came
out of that hearing.
So the first humongous bombshell that came
out of this hearing was it was exposed that
Donald Trump was supportive of the rioters
who were chanting, chanting, hang Mike Pence.
He was made aware that that was happening
and he was supportive of it.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: And aware of the rioters chants
to hang Mike Pence.
The president responded with this sentiment,
quote, Maybe our supporters have the right
idea.
Mike Pence, quote, deserves it.
Speaker 1: I know because there's already
been coverage of a lot of this and you've
priority right through your head.
You know numbed out to it but really think
about this.
The president of the United States was supportive
of a mob of people who wanted to murder his
vice president.
You would watch that?
A movie like.
That's not even something that would be fiction,
right?
If you ever heard that story, the fictional
know, the president of the United States wanted
his vice president to get murdered.
That's what we just watched.
And we can't forget that these crazy things
happen or get numbed out to them.
The next big thing I want to look at is William
Barr, Trump's attorney general, testified
in a prerecorded interview about how he looked
into it, saw there is no fraud that would
have made any difference in the election,
no wide scale widespread fraud.
And then we'll play the clip of Ivanka who
got asked about Barr's statement and pretty
much said, Yeah, I mean.
If Barr said it like I believe it.
So pretty much I don't agree with my dad's
statements.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: Told the president in no uncertain
terms that I did not see evidence of fraud.
And, you know, that would have affected the
outcome of the election.
And frankly, a year and a half later, I haven't
seen anything to change my mind on that.
How did that affect your perspective about
the election when Attorney General Barr made
that statement?
It affected my perspective.
I respect Attorney General Barr.
So I. Accepted what he was saying.
Speaker 1: So Donald Trump's attorney general
and his daughter are both well aware.
And William Barr told Trump that Trump's claims
were false and yet he kept on going with them.
And the amount of damage that that did, if
he had stopped at some point before January
6th and realized, you know what, I thought
I was dying, but looks like all the evidence
has come out.
It was actually stolen.
We would have saved so much damage from being
done to our democracy.
The next big thing that happened in the hearing
was a documentarian testified under oath.
And again, I encourage you guys to go watch
this hearing for yourself, but I'll give you
a quick summary.
So the documentarian had been allowed access
in the days leading up to January 6th and
on January 6th to follow around Enrique Tarrio,
who is the leader of the Proud Boys.
And throughout that, I guess they wanted him
or were okay with him making a documentary
about the organization or whatever was going
on and what he captured and witnessed throughout
that process proved what I mentioned earlier
that the proud boys, in coordination with
the Oath Keepers, had actually planned the
events of that day.
And we're just executing a plan to attack
the Capitol.
We'll look at some clips from that testimony
that came out.
Speaker 4: On January 5th, the night before
the attack.
You were with the head of the Proud Boys,
Mr. Tarrio in Washington, D.C..
What happened?
Speaker 5: We picked up his bags and went
to get some other bags from the Phenix Hotel.
We encountered Mr. Stuart Rhodes from the
Oath Keepers.
We drove down into the parking garage and
filmed the scene of Mr. Tarrio and Mr. Rhodes
and certain other individuals in that garage.
Speaker 3: The committee learned that the
Oath Keepers set up quick reaction forces
outside of the city in Virginia, where they
stored arms.
The goal of these quick reaction forces was
to be on standby just in case President Trump
invoked the Insurrection Act.
Did the Coopers ever provide weapons to members?
I'm going to climb to answer that.
If that's the grounds.
Speaker 1: They're acting as if they're executing
some military operation.
So after the documentarian spoke, a female
police officer recounted her experience trying
desperately to defend the Capitol.
And one of the stories she tells, she's holding
one of those bike racks that doubles as a
fence and she gets shoved backwards, hits
her head on a rail and then onto the cement
and gets knocked out cold.
So she goes through and walks through that
and then walks through the other traumatizing,
horrible things that happened and that she
witnessed that day.
That kind of brings me to my last big point
on this.
My baseline emotion watching all of this was
just rage.
At the beginning, I thought about this a lot
before, but at the beginning, because they
pointed out it was top of mind for me that
we have this long history of peaceful transition
of power.
And while you and I both know some horrible
things have happened in American history,
we've failed miserably in the past many times.
But the one thing we got right was that peaceful
transition of power and is what kept our democracy
alive.
And Donald Trump was willing to let that all
die, to let democracy in America die.
For his own gain.
For his own benefit.
Because he wanted more to believe he won and
to stay in power than just admitting he lost
the election and moving along like every other
president had done in the past.
That's a fact we cannot let people lose sight
of.
That's how deeply selfish and narcissistic
he is.
He doesn't care about the greater good of
the country because if he did, he would have
realized the claims he was making were false.
And then conceded and helped to make a peaceful
transition of power.
But that's not what he did.
I'll be getting more of my thoughts on this,
on my show.
Again, you can find that at Luke Beazley on
YouTube.
Bazley is how you spell my last name.
Or if you're watching this on YouTube or listening
to the podcast, it will be in the description
box.
A little link you can click to check me out.